welcome back to another episode of from
the point by your favorite Point brought
to you by Sprite the clear favorite we
are back on Bleacher Report got my guy
Winston again with me up you already
know yeah my boy and now this episode
we're join cut cut you going have to do
that again let me give you some energy
ah do it again do it again all right all
right welcome back to episode of from
the point by your favorite
point
a yeah no so we here we we joined by
y'all obviously have heard it the four
time NBA champion three time Finals MVP
Hall of Famer um The Legend Shaquille
O'Neal appreciate you welcome to the
show Shaq hey man first of all look at
me when you talk to me yes sir see I'm
I'm I'm going mess with y'all all night
but I'm going help y'all for sure okay
absolutely up look who you talking to
look in the camera the more views we get
the more money you get yes sir don't
don't be nervous I'm I'm a Shaq but I'm
a regular guy yep he's my favorite
player because him and Steph Curry does
something I wish I can do they're some
of the best Shooters in the league so
don't be intimidated by everything I've
done in my present right cuz this is
your money okay I know he got that NBA
money but he got two new beautiful
babies at the house you want to make all
the money you can get so [__] them no
carts yeah speak from the heart and just
ask you and don't be I I got you back
I'm going to make us all look good man
that's great that's great uh what's your
name again Winston Thomas all right
let's go Thomas um yep I'm Thomas
welcome to the show but uh when did the
when did the a start I think it was the
2021 never never been a Hulk fan okay
right played the game 19 years was a fan
19 years before that seen a lot of
things you don't really see what him
Steph and Dame do on a consistent
basement shoot from that far back that's
why Steph him and Dame they're my
favorite players and he's made it very
exciting to be a hawk fan so you know
he's a hawk and I think that's the sound
that the Hawks make and every time I
watch him play he's very exciting so I
just be trying to you know get people
involved let people know who he is
because in this thing of virus there's a
lot of guys that's me me me me me me me
me me but I don't in there done that and
got paid it's time to pass the love Trey
is that guy in Atlanta and I live in
Atlanta I want to show him and his
family as much as support that I can so
when I do the the a thing nobody was
doing it and it just brings you know
attention to to him brings attention to
the Hawks and whenever I do it they win
so you know I played I did a lot of
things but I was a guy that jealousy
always made me go to the next level when
I first came man that was the first pick
this and that but you go around the
Charles Barkley and the Jordan and the
magic and all the love that they got
makes you just a little bit but then
makes you say okay here I come so when I
watch him Stephen
Dame I wish I had that and like so when
when I'm on NBA 2K I'm them when I'm at
the crib around my boys I don't do dunks
and do post moves I'm I'm like I'm like
Trey Steph Curry D us so you know it's
just my love and support for him and the
thing cuzz he he's one of my favorite
players well I appreciate that I've
always appreciated you showing me love I
know you recently just they just
announced that you're going to get your
jersey retired in Orlando um I know
that's where you started your career you
you made your name even more in other
places but that's where you started so
what does that mean uh getting your
jersey retired in Orlando where you
started I don't know if you know about
my my high school career but when I
first started out I was the guy that
wasn't good enough so sophomore year got
cut wasn't good enough coach said I and
I was living in Germany I wasn't even in
the States coach said you're not good
enough but I'm the guy that I love to
prove people wrong so got back to the
States junior year 35
one 36 and0 win the state championship
but what it taught me is that life is
like goes up and down because I went
from nothing to the number one player in
Texas now when I go to LSU it's a guy
that's similar to him his name was
formerly known as Chris Jackson mmud
Abdul his name shoot that thing just
like him so now I'm at the bottom again
but I had the blueprint on how to work
hard so uh now I'm the number one player
in college the number one pick now when
I get to the NBA I come in at number 30
right even though I'm the number one
pick it's still guys ahead of me so now
I said okay so it just knew I knew I had
to work hard I enjoyed working hard cuz
I wanted that spot so luckily when I got
drafted to by Orlando they were not a
good team so I had the triple green
light right away so when you get the
triple green light I knew what to do
with it I know I had to just keep
getting better and keep getting better
and you know the business of basketball
took over I didn't finish my career
there after four years I decided to you
know do something else but for them to
to give me the call and say hey we want
to retire your jersey I think it's a
wonderful thing uh Dwight is probably
next if they do another one penny
Hardway should definitely be in that
conversation but to to be the first have
my jersey retired the Lando I think it's
a wonderful thing cuz I knew I had to
put in work like when I talk to the
youngsters I tell them don't be
satisfied when you reach your goal
because there's more goals to reach like
when I first got in I was making 40 for
seven I was like damn I'm one of the
highest paid players and then big dog
was talking about 100 million I was like
man I got to pick my game up then I got
100 million and I got another extension
I got another extension so you know even
though I emerged as you know one of the
top young players that that wasn't
enough for me you and Will Chamberlain
are the only two players in NBA history
to have your jersey retired by that piss
me off why because listen we all like
titles I wanted to be the first like
like I always tell people when you talk
about the grades of all time if I'm not
unanimous don't even bring it
up like so you know when when they talk
about the most dominant it's one or two
names I'm happy with that conversation
but it would be more empowering to me
they say Shaq was the most dominant
player ever MH see like see like him
when it comes to the greatest SHO is him
and three other guys I don't know how he
feels about that but I never like that
so when my mother told me the other day
she's like baby in a second I was happy
but I was pissed because I wanted to be
the first like for example I would have
been the first unanimous MVP but one guy
gave one vote to another guy so Steph
became the first unanimous that's also
pissed me off but I'm happy about it but
when I played I was always searching for
titles because I like to because I like
to stand alone do you think anybody else
will will achieve that feat maybe LeBron
Cleveland Miami and La maybe yeah LeBron
maybe and you already mentioned Dwight
is probably gonna be the next Orland of
magic so that's great do you think it's
long overdue um I know they it's always
an honor for them retiring to Jersey now
and whenever it happens but I mean I'm
thinking of guys like Penny I think of
guys like you like I try not to complain
a
lot you know how the business of
basketball is they're going to do what
they want to do and if they decide to do
it but if I have to solicit you to do
something
then really should it be done mhm like
when they talk about the top 75 if you
have to State your case on why you're
not top 75 my question is are you really
top 75 again I keep going back there
when they talk about the best Shooters
in the game his name gonna always come
up because he one of the best Shooters
in the game it ain't oh what about what
about this guy that so so like if you're
on that side of the conversation I never
want to be on that conversation it is or
it isn't and if it ain't or if you have
to think about it don't even mention my
name that's a great Point actually so
you uh you made it to the finals in year
three but didn't win your first ring
until year eight you talk about that
Medium you know what it took to get over
the hump what what did it take for you
to get over the hump and take that next
jump as a player and be able to lead
your team to actually win a ring Trey
understands this when you're the best
guy everything falls back on
you so my advice to him is to make sure
he's always ready make sure he gets his
guys ready first championship I take
full responsibility but not being us
ready because we celebrated too early
everybody was scared of Michael Jordan I
was not that's why I wi thousands of
dollars in Betts who was the last per
person to beat Michael Jordan nobody
knows oh he went six and0 like oh yeah
remember the year when he came off when
he took off and came back and they
played us I'm the last guy to beat him
so after we beat him he was happy and me
D Scott we had about nine 10 days off we
had a lot of meetings at Magic
City you know what Magic City is I do
know what yeah so we we we we we had 10
days off and it's like bro we beat Mike
we good we about to take it and we had
play well against theem so you know they
won one we won one wasn't intimidating
him showed him probably too much respect
in the finals which is why he dogged me
out in the finals but I didn't know what
it took to win a championship and that's
why I always said if I ever got back I
have to dominate I got to do what I do
like okay you're averaging 309 you got
to bring it up to 40 you got to tuck
that elbow in on the free throw line and
and at least shoot 60% you're not going
to shoot 78% right now you're shooting
50 but down by one we need this free
throw so I had to step up as a player
had to make sure everybody else was
ready and uh it was something that I I I
I wanted so you know when when you're
that guy Trey you got to take it take it
take it upon yourself to make sure it
gets done every time because when we do
well we get all the credit when we don't
do well that's how I fault then they
start talking nonsense like trading us
and like it's just the business of
basketball is very very difficult but if
you have that leading mentality you have
to do it your way and do it the correct
way I feel like it'll ultimately work
out like it did for you I hope that
that's how it works out for me but for
me that's before we get into the Lakers
like if you had to
judge your version of Shaq and Magic
your version vers La Shaq
what do you think the pros and cons for
both of them were what was better The
Shaq in Orlando was a
runner that's because I used to get the
ball Penny was a pass first guy when I
got to LA and guys you know wanting to
do their own thing rightfully so had to
slow it down a little bit and you know
just say okay you know so when you get
the ball do your thing right when I get
down here make sure I get to do my thing
uh the LA Shack was more dominant
more
focused have better help around me and
the general didn't Panic what I mean by
the general is and like I always say
it's on TNT if the general doesn't panic
which is the coach then the players
won't panic because I've been in a
situation where coaches don't know what
to do and then Phil was like nope I'm
not calling the time out you guys figur
it out he treated us like men and he let
us figure out and I had another dog next
to me that's not I'm not going to see
her act like I did it by myself I had a
I had a dog next to me who wanted to who
had the same mentality that that I had
and if I'm going average 40 he he was
going to try to average 39 so that's 79
points right there so you get that then
you get everybody else stepping up we
were we were supposed to win and we did
win and that growth as a player I'm sure
you had people in your ear both on and
off the court that were very difficult
of you that were very challenging of the
player that you were trying to become um
you have been that for a lot of guys now
in the league too you've been critical
of Zion you've been critical of Donovan
Mitchell Joel and B
what type of responsibility do you feel
as an ex nbaer that's still around the
game to be able to see only advise these
guys only a negative person would look
at it as critical but if you know who
you are you should look at it as
information and I've said this the many
times like if I look at him and say he
shouldn't have took that shot he's
either gonna say okay I'm G keep taking
it and make it this time or shut you up
or he's going to listen to what I'm
saying like you know what maybe I should
step in not making fun don't need to
make fun when I give you
information I'm giving it to you raw I'm
giving it to you like I would give it to
you if we was playing if I was playing
with him and he took a crazy shot while
I'm in the post I would say Trey don't
take that shot right but again as a
player you know who you are shq shut
your ass up watch this you hit five in a
row I can't say nothing right or you
listen to what the big man is saying
who's won for Championship say you know
what maybe he's right so a negative
person will look at oh he's hating I
can't hate giving you information what I
what I've always not learned about
criticizing especially from players
that's been there and done that if
you've been there and done that I will
listen to you right and if you do
criticize me I will look I will listen
to that and see if there's some truth
into that like Shaq could be one of the
greatest players ever but he was a
terrible free throw shooter he can't
can't be mad at that it's the truth yeah
I average 40 and Jordan average 39 I did
that but there's some truth in what
you're saying really can't get mad so I
learned that when I was in LA I was
putting up big numbers and they ask
Kareem Kareem what you think my Shaq and
Kareem said with a straight fa yeah I
think I know y'all think he's a great
player but is he a really great player
they ain't winning how can I get mad at
that that's Kareem so when I say
something with the G14 classification I
had can't be hate because I've been
there and I've done everything that you
guys are trying to do is really
information so when I say I watch Zion
he he wasn't running he wasn't trying to
get easy points for himself and he
wasn't trying to take LeBron spot a lot
of times I I try to put myself in in the
mindset and and listen we all have the
same mindset like when Trey see a guy
come and guard him one onone we all got
the same mind said this [__]
can't guard me give it to him so when
I'm sitting there in Vegas and all that
thing going on I'll say to myself Z
going to say you know what forget you
LeBron this [__] is mine now and I
didn't see that and I mention it so they
made think is it's it's criticism and
hate but it's information but do you
think do you think every Legend like you
things like that no and I and I think a
lot of Legends don't have to have the
the capability and the classification to
say what they say I agree so I can
understand why y'all are mad because I
used to get mad like like Charles love
him great player but how do you know
what it takes to get to the big dance
and whenn you don't and that's no
disrespect so I'm not going to listen to
you so
again it it it it depends on how it's
said and how you say it but me I don't
have room to hate brother I got too much
stuff to do but when I see somebody that
I like I respect I'm G say it how I
would say it as if we were on the same
team well that's that's how I feel like
like I mean I'm I'm the first person to
tell somebody that I don't know it all
and I I'm although I'm i' made I've done
a lot of things in my career I haven't
achieved the best things and the highest
things and I know I still got a lot to
improve and a lot to show but I can
still learn some things but you can also
hear the hate in some of some old school
and some Legends voice and even though
like they they can be some of the best
players
ever you can still still hear it a
little bit in their voice yeah but I I
always say from a place of love because
you have to you have to understand the
same thing I would tell you in your
face cuz it's all about
respect Trey I don't like that shot
don't mean I'm hating on you I don't
like the shot Trey you the guy on the
team but that was like I understand you
can hit a 30 footer but that was 35 my
guy right bring that [__] back to where
you from like d bro we down by one I I'm
not telling you not to do what you do
but that's 35 ft dog bring that [__] to
30 or 32 or 33 the same thing I would
tell him as a friend as a brother so so
like when I say something that sounds
like hate you should slow it down and
listen to what I'm saying people think I
hate Dwight for what yeah I I don't see
I'm saying bro you got to average 28
tend to be dominant right and then if
you do that then it ain't no no question
on on whether you're top 75 or not yeah
if you do that and play like this you
top 75 it ain't no why do you think some
of your peers are like that though like
because you know why be honest they need
this [__] they need it okay they need to
be be feel they they they need to be
heard they want people to know that
they're important I don't need to be
important I'm either important or I'm
not yep but I'm not going to go
overboard to say hey how important you
either think Shaq's dominant big man or
you don't right and I'm not going to be
doing stuff to to prove that I am either
you know or you don't so when I used to
hear criticism I used to say okay and I
use it as motivation and it helped me I
I love being criticized because I'm I'm
I have the ability enough to slow down
time and read what you said and if
there's some truth in okay watch it like
oh file them file them every now and
then [__] go six out of 10 seven
out of 12 nine out of nine like okay you
going to follow me cuz you think I okay
watch this and every just and it helped
me win four championships so you know a
lot of these players should take the
criticism and and turn into Mo
motivation sound like you yeah I mean me
and me and Shad don't have a lot of
similarities as far as our game but I
feel like I mean our mentality and from
just hearing you speak and from years
going we have a lot in that that eyes
but going over to this big man Alliance
I know you have guys that you put in
your your little list of your big man
alliances and you consider them in this
list like I know you put the Joker in it
as far as today's game is there any
other guys that you see I mean in
today's game that you could put in there
or have the capabilities of being on
their way
Joker
embiid b b but he's lazy as hell man he
has so much talent man he's lazy you
know people try to jump on me when I
when they said I was comparing him and
wimy was not comparing him and wimy like
like I I tell like Charles and Reggie
all the time relax relax relax
like wimy did something and he's 75 very
talented player not hating him all
really good but he wasn't the first to
do it bo b was the first seven foot guy
five guy to bring it and and do it with
style because a lot of like for example
no no disrespect Clint capella could
dribble but it don't look like how how
there look what I'm saying so bbo was
the first to do it with style you know
social media going to change around
compare him not compare him just saying
he was the first wimy is in
there and tell it's only four because I
like I like big guys that demand
attention big guys that can play and I
know the game is different the game is
different now like I I wish I could
shoot I wish I had the ability to do a
joker and like I'm I'm I'm jealous of
those guys because as much as you talk
about me I didn't have that
if I had that I think i' would have been
a much more exciting player so those
four but
poo I don't know what it is like I I
coach him one game for a and I had him
doing stuff I've never seen a guy his
size can do it that's why I know
firsthand I know what he can do but he
just doesn't get out and do it but wimy
he played you guys last night he he was
impressive in the second half he was
very very impressive he was pivoting
that a little bit if there was a guard
Alliance one who do you think would be I
like all Shooters because you know why I
seen all that I've seen the handle bro
I've been around this game a long time
stuff that him Dame and Steph do I ain't
seen that and it's consistently you can
hit a you can hit one 35 footer or 40f
footer but they do it all the time they
do it too much some done but a lot of
time it goes in and make crowd go crazy
so you know the way I I look at those
that in like a different category so I
don't like I wouldn't put like Luca and
Kyrie and that's no disrespect to those
guys that similar game but you're asking
me so this is what I say those three
some of the you know top guards in the
game there's a lot of young guys that
doing the thing but I enjoy stuff that I
haven't seen before and I I haven't seen
guys do it like that consistently and as
long as they've been doing it have been
doing it a long time long time well no I
mean it's been bus and doing it for I
got a question how the hell you can
shoot from that deep but I can't I I
know I know I'm stronger than you but
like I be at the house I'm like I'm me
shooting there it's like it's like
football players you can't lift all them
weights and then just expect no but like
the ball weighs how much I don't I think
it's two pound something like that bro
when I'm at the house I'm trying to
shoot from that deepest airball City and
you little guys I'm like no it's touch
it's touch make me so mad it's touch but
uh out of all your years with the Lakers
I mean everybody knows those years and
from watching you and Co play what was
your favorite what was your favorite
championship year probably the first one
because after all we've been through
with Phil we almost let it slip away and
I can remember in the fourth quarter
Phil was a genius CU you know he came he
said all right guys let's just finish
this game out come back next year and
try and we were like what and then we
collectively Co like n the championship
no this is the game seven vers Portland
okay we were down I think 15 to 17
points he came he said all right guys
hey you I'm proud of you guys Shaq you
gotb prime but we're not gonna win this
game today let's just play it out see
what like he was he was he was like
testing us to see if we wanted to
quit Cole was like nah you know Cole N I
ain't going out like that and then I
wasn't having a really good game but I
know that you know if you're playing
terrible and you keep playing you can
pick it up like I'm never going to stop
like I'll go zero for for 40 before I'll
I'll give up so I was like okay all I
need is two or three these jump hooks to
fall and I'm going to get back on track
right and then you know the others who I
call everybody stepped it up so we just
kept cut it to nine cut it to 10 I shoot
a baseline jump hook Kobe does what he
does and I'm telling Kobe the whole game
hey when you get to the rim instead of
doing all that I'm right there I'm right
there and and that play that everybody
talks about he cross pipping up and he
threw it up he threw the [__] up
too high he threw it up too high but I'm
I'm stopping time if I miss this and we
lose going to be my fault [__] that go
get that
[__] that [__] threw it
down so now this game over so now
remember what I told you earlier yeah
okay I got two days off I'm getting
[__] 40 and game one in the finals I
don't give a [__] who we playing so I
was able to to take that moment and get
back so that that was a good one and
then you know us as athletes all right
you got one can you get too all the
[__] who didn't have G14
classification and they still wasn't
giving me my props oh you almost lost
that game oh and and you know even
though you won your first championship
you wasn't playing against somebody all
right I'm gonna get another one and we
win number two and the same [__]
thing I'm like okay yeah you got two and
Co and Shaq arguing can they get three
I'm like okay now I got to get three so
you know all that stuff that they said
and the guys who didn't really have the
G14 class creation say all that stuff
that they were saying instead of
knocking people out every time I see
them I said okay I'm about to shut you
the [__] up yeah I'm about to I'm about
to make you say my name with some
respect and I urge you to start doing
the same thing you ain't got to go back
and forth with people and get and if you
get mad keep that [__] right there
because a lot of times I say stuff just
to test people out like the fact when I
said that stuff about Zion and he didn't
get mad shows me he not ready yet he'll
be ready he's still young but I seen him
play Mad in high school I saw one clip
where they had a guy his size ging him
he took that [__] personal he that he
had about 90 dunks so a lot of time when
I say stuff it may sound crazy but if
you know me as a person I'm not that guy
I want everybody to eat M cuz these guys
are eating good now oh I'm so jealous of
these guys making 200 350 but it's a
good feeling to have all that so if I
see something you're not doing it and
you know I played at that high level I'm
I'm G throw it out there but I'm not
going to always going be like Trey you
taking a bad shot Trey stop shooting
that [__] baby yeah yeah Trey man you
like but it's it's coming from you know
a place L and the the dog that I know he
is he not GNA he gonna be like all right
Shaq watch this and come back and shoot
that [__] again and make it or
he gonna listen to me and just come in a
little bit so you know that this is what
I urge players to Beast stop being
sensitive because I know what I'm
talking about and you know I know what
I'm talking about but I I try not to I'm
G try to do a better job of not making
it sound like I'm embarrassing them but
no man n you ain't got to you ain't got
to stop I feel I feel like n cuz the
real ones get it like I feel like the
the best players respond like Joel
responded like I feel like MVP you know
what I'm saying dominating you you were
talking about him before he was MVP so
it's like it's it's just about the best
players going to respond so I mean if
you won't respond when a you can tell a
legend is giving you advice to only help
you that's on them you shouldn't feel
sorry about you know they need to
understand I don't have to hate brother
like all the stuff you're doing I'm
passing it on because because I got it
from Mike and magic and those guys and
bro I can't make all the money so if I
can help you get 250 to 500 I'm GNA help
you brother do you think there's a
reason why the dynamic among current
players has changed to be a little bit
more sensitive to to what you would you
would not call criticism but other
people view it as oh he hating or or
whatever if if you're not if you've if
You' never been that good and you got a
podcast now you're talking greasy
that'll never be taken respectfully
right like some of these C that podcast
I'm like come on bro you wasn't that
good like like don't talk like you was
that guy I was that guy I can talk like
this see you have the understanding
about me if I'm not that guy I'm not
going to talk like I was that guy but
you know I was that guy so I'll say it
but again I I say like is if if is if
you're my boy is if you're my teammate
like if I got to embarrass you I'm not
gonna embarrass you here when I see you
I'm going say something to you that's
the type of guy I am so if if I mention
your name means I love you and respect
you like I used to love dght he he did
something I couldn't do I wish I could
jump that high I love dght High a lot of
people don't know that this my first
time saying it but as a big brother I
ain't going to let my little brother
slide so I want you to be better than me
so like a lot of people who don't
understand this thing of ours they think
it's it's hate no it ain't hate I'm
telling you how to get here you know I'm
here dog I'm telling you how to get here
if you don't want to get here that's on
you and you know and that's why I kind
of had to like you know lay off them a
little bit but yeah you describing
mentorship and I think that's something
that we obviously talk about all the
time of people we look up to in our
lives that's on the court that's off the
court too I know youve you have your
hand in a bunch of different things off
the court this some where where both
sarting Tre is really uses platform to
to control his own narrative and what
advice would you give Trey as he's kind
of starting to explore the marketplace a
little bit outside of basketball I will
always tell Trey
one I call it singleand stress so let me
give you an example my
mother my
kids my
boys my organization my money I don't
give a [__] about what they think see
right now it's too much information
being spread and too many people have
the word if it don't make sense don't
care I made this quote for my kids if
nobody can influence somebody then the
nobody
wins right but the question of the day
is who the [__] are you nobody if you
can't shoot from 10 feet don't tell him
how to [__] shoot shot from right I
want to hear it mmud Abdul R could give
him some advice they in that same
category I can't right but I know good
shot bad shot I can say it's the bad but
I can't tell him about his no be quiet
so my advice to him is listen to those
people your
wife second of all do it your
way do it your way because if you do it
their way and it doesn't work out you're
still going to get the blame if you do
it your way and it doesn't work out you
can live with that cuz now you can go
back and say maybe I need to do this and
I do that whenever I did it my way I
would win whenever I did it their way I
end up getting traded so just do it your
way continue to play and continue to
better yourself and I don't know what
motivates him but jealousy always
motivated me like right now he's two or
three I would I would be upset at that
like for example I'm not trying to
disrespect him but I think Steph is a
better shooter than him I don't know how
he feels about that but if I was him be
like all right Shaq watch this [__] so I
I would always take stuff like that to
just to just get me going and like when
you when you have that mentality it it
it will definitely drive you and when
it's all said and done your name will be
talked about indefit it's not who's the
better shooter I like I I know him like
first time I seen him like I knew he was
but I saw when he went back to the crib
and some cat was challenging him and he
[__] embarrassed that cat this clip
right
here that's for your
editors see that that's when I knew he
had some dog yeah I like him cuz like he
he coming back to show the town love and
this cat who not even in the league
talking that [__] and he shot the
[__] gym down I said oh he's
one of us me bring him over here he's
one of us met his parents talk to his
dad know who his dad was did my research
see how he growing up I like this
[__] trade right here ah every
time I so I know when I jump on him I
know he knows what he knows how to
decode it what would you say motivates
you the most I mean he Shaq mentioned
like about about that name you know what
I'm saying like making sure you like you
representing your name like for me my
grandpa who passed when I was 10 years
old is who I prayed before talked to
before every game I step on the court
like I'm representing not only the city
and this organization and all my fans
but my last name so like I want to
represent it the right way and I know I
mean I want to win championships like
that that's only going to enhance that
last name enhance my family enhance
everything around me so that's what
motivates me is just making sure I
protect my last name and making sure I
represented the right way aside from you
know off the court and all that this
broadcast thing is new for us too we're
we we're about what six months into
podcasting um you've been in the game
for a while now what what advice would
you give I don't want to give you you're
doing a beautiful job thank you see even
though it's broadcasting it's not just
be yourself we already got too many
broadcasting shows nobody want to see
that [__] be
yourself like the podcast world is a
great world because it gives regular
people a chance to you know everybody
can't be Ernie everybody can't be Adam
let go but they give us the lane to be
ourselves don't bro you seven cameras
you're a crew do what the [__] you want
to do yeah people either going to like
it or they don't but don't I don't I
don't I don't give
advice it may sound like I'm giving
advice I'm not really giving you advice
I'm just giving you Clues but I'm not a
podcast expert that ain't my Lane like I
got a podcast very successful but I'm
not the podcast king so I'm I'm not Pat
mcae those guys so if you want to get
information guy that has 100 million
subscribers you could probably ask him
this question but I don't step outside
my Lane basketball [__] I'm that guy but
this thing right here I I think it's a
beautiful show that's why I did it did
it cuz my guy right here he's my guy
and if I can help you guys in any way go
viral and get more views and get more
money that that's what that's what
you're supposed to do as old the player
Dr J did that [__] for me Dr J and Magic
Johnson and Michael Jordan and Barkley
is like young fell come on in so that's
what I try to do for fell so I don't
have no advice your shit's beautiful and
whoever don't like it [__] him I know
for me like I I can't get off this this
show without asking you about one of my
favorite players Kobe so somebody who I
was able to talk to and meet a couple
times growing up as a kid I know you
have a lot of memories what was one of
your favorite memories as as a teammate
with them so all the stuff I do now with
players I did with him not saying that I
made him great but when you got a dog
you agitate him when you got a kill a
pit bull you don't pet him you piss him
off and make sure he stays that pit bull
so all the stuff I'm doing now is what I
did with him and it worked for him so if
it worked for him hey I'm trying to
[__] you shooting too much
[__] you doing this [__]
this ain't your team this my [__] like
it's just to because I need them right
and again I already know what I'm gonna
do because I don't want [__]
bumbs talking [__] I'm giving you 2810
yeah period free throws or not that's
what I'm doing every night I don't want
y'all talking that [__] about me what
the [__] you gonna do Trey you ain't
going to do [__] tonight [__]
Atlanta is my city right just just to
keep them going
and it work so CU remember you know Kobe
wasn't always Kobe like when he came in
he was a young guy and he had to be
molded so those first three years carry
my bags you ain't gonna be like it it
just [__] drove him crazy and he
wanted to be great he wanted to be
better than me what you're supposed to
do he wouldn't be better than Mike and
it just kept going and boom boom boom
boom bo boom boom like a lot of people
ask me what would you do different I
wouldn't do nothing different because it
would be a better story if we didn't win
any man they couldn't get along but it's
not about getting along it's about you
doing your job my doing my job us making
sure the others do our job and we win
championships we won three out of four I
wouldn't do nothing different you know
reason why I got traded not because we
were having problem because they wanted
me to take less money that ain't gonna
happen going happen so you know but me
being the marketing guy I am I made it I
don't [__] with you but it's not it's
not like that in real life and as a
leader of the team that's what I had to
do to get them going I don't want to be
nice to that kid you you but so he but
he had it all and what I like about him
because I'm the guy I used to do my
thing I'm not the I'm not the guy that
practice seven hours a day I don't need
to like I hear a lot of people say well
if Shaq would have worked out hard I
would have been what I'd have been
[__] Shaq
[__] I'm gonna give you the same
outcome what have been me but I'm not
the guy that's going to work seven hours
cuz when I step on the court I already
know you can't guard me I already know
you can't guard me so I'm not doing no
extra working out I'm coming in the camp
out of shape CU I know I'm GNA play back
in shape and by the end of the season
playoffs I'm busting your ass
anyway he was the guy
that right and I knew that so it was my
job to make sure he always played that
level what I loved about the most is
especially like when we came to Atlanta
[__] I'm going
out I'm GNA start off slow co go ahead
you take it and like he he wanted it so
I'm like Co I would come and say Co and
100 out of 100 time coob I need 40 boom
like last game I we was messing around
said coob I need 50 [__] went
out got 60 he been doing that since not
18 since 20 years old and I knew that
like you know if I if I needed him we
can do it but I'm not the guy he he
doesn't respond to nice he responds like
[__] this this my [__] and I knew it it
ate him up aive but that was my tactic
to keep him going and you know a lot of
people don't know that and understand
that but from the outside looking that
oh that ain't get along we got along
enough to win three out of four so what
the hell are you talking about
look when I got double I'm looking for
him and when he cross up he at the top
of the key he looking for me for the
love and that's what it's all about like
I don't know how you and your teammates
are but the respect always have to be
there but I'm I'm not going out when I
go to a city I'm G do what the [__] I
want to do about myself I going to a
hookah bar going to a movie I ain't
trying to eat dinner at bro I just saw
you practicing on the plane ride get
away from me but on that Court double
team Rick Fox double team big shabat you
had the show to respect so you know a
lot of people who don't know really know
our story they they're going to always
say oh but no but I the same things I'm
doing with these players now is the
exact same thing I did with him I added
him all to a point he was so pissed off
at me but it worked out in everybody's
favor he definitely did did it
definitely did there are some common
questions that I feel like the fan
myself like you said you you have that
but you but you have that general you
know G14 classification that I'll never
have so I'm still a fan of the game I'm
I'm happy to say that I always be a fan
of the game what is one common
misconception about today's game that
you don't feel like the fan behind the
scenes understands I think a lot of us
including
myself we wanted to be like when we
played I have to accept that it's
different I don't like all you guys
running the same pick and role play that
bothers me
but it's how it is we got to respect it
we got to expect it so I try to get away
from it but it's just just different I
played an era where the flring fouls y
are getting were not fling foul so a lot
of us we think it's soft but we have to
get away from that I realize it's it's
not it's it's their time it's not our
time and we have to get away from that
and and I'm going try but you know the
fact that that the big men are up there
when it comes to the the MVP categor
that makes me happy but as a fan I I
don't like watching 2017s run the same
pick and roll dribble handle I I don't
like that but we have to accept it yeah
the game was definitely different back
back in the day like no I mean for me
like I I appreciate you coming on
anything for you my guy like you you a
legend and you know I'm G stay on you
only because I love you I already
already know okay cool if I got if I got
something personal say I got your number
but it ain't going to never be like that
but if I because again we we're both in
the same category [__] go bad they
looking at you they're not looking at
Clint and not looking at De jante muray
looking at the man and the day you
accept that is the day your game going
to be even better so you have to lead
them you have to play great every night
which you can't have no games off and
you just gota you just got to do what
you do well one thing that I always I
mean I've already taken from you and you
ain't even told me it's just from
listening to you is great players can't
have two bad games in a row never and um
I
mean and uh so that's that's something
i' I've always thought about and there
constant things so I'm always listening
to you so I appreciate it and don't make
people change your game just tighten it
up like I don't mind you shooting 35
long the [__] go in go in Trey
bring that [__] to
29 28 29 that's all I got you I got you
man this is amazing we appreciate you
stopping by thank you anytime from the
point much I'll I'll do the outro later
man forget it like this
this mother this is so dope the point by
your favorite point we out peace
[Music]
y'all heard that I just got stamped by
Shack definitely couldn't get out of
here without thanking our presenting
sponsor Sprite for that crisp lemon lime
taste it's a clear favorite
peace